marker  whenever you're ready ready peter are  you hiding something  with great power comes great  responsibility are you doing  batman where are shy okay that's not  even the right cinematic universe yes it  is  no it's definitely not you're wrong it  is there's been crossovers there has  i've seen them tom if you keep doing  this we're gonna get sued i have so much  money i'm batman  no you're not batman  tom i don't want you to take this the  wrong way but you were a horrible  auditioner  shut up or i'll break you i was born in  the darkness  i don't like this i feel like i crushed  this  no part's mine have you ever even read a  comic book tom  yeah justice avengers is the one that's  nope that's not one series 27 you should  check it out  series 27 of what of comic books  okay we're done you're done okay i'm in  you have to leave  you